Trent good morning thanks for joining us
how are you alright I don't know how
impressed I should be with the Rams I
know that we do overreact but I'm
curious as a former quarterback who
played at a high level and you look at
Jared Goff what is the difference now
with golf as opposed to two years ago or
even last year well I think it's anytime
you have that perfect blend of talented
quarterback great play caller skilled
people around you know a lot of pieces
around you you're gonna see this
progression of a quarterback and the
confidence come out I think that's the
biggest thing is total command you know
so low confidence of what he's doing
he's a very very gifted player it really
bothers me when I hear people say just a
system guy like they minimize his talent
he's a pure pure pass there has been
since he was 17 years old I got to coach
Little League 11 as tremendous feel for
the passing game his play of arm Talent
he can threaten all areas of the field
he can throw it or you can throw guys
open he could layer of ourselves and
he's really nothing he can't do with the
football I think at Cal he didn't have
the total command of the position
because of protection schemes and now
with McVeigh and the protection plans
they have in place and all the tools
they give him at the line of scrimmage
he can play the game on his terms he can
get to the plays that he wants to get to
he can get himself protected they have a
great running game obviously and I think
what you're seeing is is the fullness of
a guy when you put the right pieces
around them I've been really impressed
like everybody else has this year but I
was impressed last year for a
second-year guy that had a rough rookie
year to be able to grow in the position
and win a bunch of games and be highly
productive that's what you're looking
for in your quarterback what would be
your big concern with the Rams defense
probably I mean they're loaded personnel
wise but they play this that this has
always been waived deal that he plays a
style of defense that when a team can
attack the inside of the football field
when they can get you know when they can
get skilled players matched up on
linebackers
when they can get big plays against them
that that defensive scheme has a
tendency to get gashed but I don't you
know they're gonna be playing from the
lead so with the lead so much and like
you just mentioned before I came on
their division is so poor and I don't
have a whole lot of concerns for them in
the regular season it'll come down to
playoff football and if they're built
for playoff football how healthy they
are at the end of the year and whether
they can you know I think one thing you
see at the Rams is yes they will run the
ball early gets a lot of touches but
they definitely want to throw it down
the field like what they want to do more
than anything else is great chunk plays
in the passing game I think when you do
get into playoff football and if you
have to go on the road and play some
more in bad weather you got to be
stubborn with your running back and are
they willing to be stubborn with getting
earlier the ball in situations when they
normally want to throw it how concerned
would you be if you're a Vikings fan
today I'd be concerned but I'm
definitely not an early season panic guy
anymore
the one thing I had learned the last
four or five years is September is still
the preseason you can you can lose it in
September but you can't win it I don't
think they've lost it yet yeah yeah
they're there behind the eight ball a
little bit with last night's loss but
teams are still learning in September
now that with the limited offseason
practice with as little as starters
playing the preseason we see this every
year and I've made a mistake of
knee-jerk reacting in September you
really can't teams are just starting to
figure out who they are I think October
is more telling than September but I
would not panic as a Vikings fan there
well coach there are lots of good
players they've been there done that
I think they'll correct the things have
gotten into trouble at this point I
think they'll be a contender by the end
I know that you've learned your lesson
you said over the last couple of years
which leads me to the Patriots the
Patriots after a one and two start if
the Patriots lose to the Dolphins
dot-dot-dot finish that sentence
I'd be very concerned but I would write
them off they don't look the same but
they are getting Adelman back they will
grow offensively I can see them trying
to run the ball a little bit more
bothered me the other night it was them
not be able to convert on third and
short you know they're one of the better
34 teams the league in the past I think
they'll fix those things with coach Gard
Nekia their offensive line coach again
they're the team you can never write off
because they're all about development
they're all about how they are in week 9
more than what they are week two three
four so their history alone would be
would make me say I would still give
them a very long leash even affair to
lose the Dolphins talking to Trent
Dilfer former NFL quarterback also
contributes to the NFL Network's
Thursday night pregame show with the
soul and science segments if I said you
can have a quarterback for the next five
years we have a draft coming up next
hour and you could you could you could
pick any quarterback and you get him at
his current age but you're getting for
the next five years you had the number
one overall pick and you would take
questions right now I just doing this
with Ryan or so the other day I probably
go when and that's hard I mean there's
there's seven eight good options but I'd
probably go with when would you take
Aaron Rodgers at age 34 if you had him
for the next five years probably not and
I was the one that probably not this cuz
age I mean he's obviously one of the
greatest of all time he does things that
you know literally make your draw jaw
drop every time you watch him play but
again this is well the hardest question
isn't all football right now and there's
really no wrong answer with between
seven eight nine guys but I would
probably go at Carson Wentz
explain what you're doing with the NFL
NFL Players Association the exclusive
trading card partner there what's the
contest pattern Bouldin yeah panini
America I've been doing this for four
years now it's really cool they every
year they do a Super Bowl kid reporter
initiative
kids by their trading cards over the
country some of the cards have a code on
the back you enter that code if you win
you get to go to the Super Bowl media
night with me I coach them up on how to
ask questions they go around to the
boost they get front of line and get to
ask these players really cool questions
it's been it's been a thrill for me to
watch the joy in these kids faces as
they've been able to do it but the
surprising thing that's come out of it
is you've been the media night a million
times these players are kind of kind of
done with it you know I mean there's two
other people at their booth there's all
these weird questions but when they see
the kid they light up they love engaging
with the kid the kid asked some great
questions the player loves the kid loves
it it's been one of the coolest things
I've been able to do in my first career
with panini America and I just love the
initiative and I love doing it every
year you can go to panini kid reporter
calm for more details I'll leave you
with this Trent because I know you're
involved in these seven on seven and
eleven on 11 and all these camps there
and these kids coming out of high school
going into college they're ready to play
right away in these 5-star recruits we
just saw this with Clemson where you got
Trevor Lawrence who's coming in and
Kelly Bryan who's been you know a
decorated starter at Clemson as a senior
you know he's transferring now the I
guess the ability for these kids to
comprehend what they need to learn in
college at that early of an age and now
we're looking at juniors and seniors
where you might be expendable at that
position do you see this is a new wave
where the five stars are coming in and
for two years or three years maybe and
then after that you got another five
star coming in and he might be
expendable yes I do think it's gonna be
a trend quarterbacks are just getting
better every year think of it this way
they've aglow believe that this is the
really kids now it's been the first time
in the history of football where these
kids when they were eight nine ten years
old could find as much quarterback
information as you could possibly ever
want out there between private
quarterback coaches watching Amazon
Prime of Tom Brady or Jared Goff and the
Rams or
everything we do with the lead 11 well
your eight nine ten eleven years old you
have access to every bit of quarterback
information you could ever possibly want
then you're throwing a football you're
playing in seven on seven you're playing
in the fall you're being trained
privately your your your learning curve
has been accelerated so much
well now you add all the talent now
you're adding also the biggest strong
the toughest kid now playing court most
athletic kids playing quarterback it's
kind of the perfect storm where every
year we go around the country and we
evaluate about 750 to a thousand
quarterbacks and we see now we caught
the elite 11 and we do 24 guys go to 12
but we see 50 guys every year 50 to 75
guys that are so much better than I ever
was or that Tony Romo ever was or
because we have all these quarterbacks
come out and join us on the tour and
they go are you kidding me
these kids are so much better than I was
and these are pro guys that played 1215
years the NFL so you're just seeing
waves of quarterbacks in high school I
live in Texas now I go to high school
football games on Friday night and every
week I go to a game and I see a
quarterback that was better than me I
mean it's crazy how many good
quarterbacks there are so you're gonna
see every year these colleges get
somebody that has a chance to be really
really good but who is playing now that
you saw in high school where you went
he's got star written all over him or
I'm surprised that he's got star written
all over oh gosh I can go down I mean
85% of the power by quarterbacks are
lean 11 guys they're 22 and NFL orally
11 guys I mean I remember seeing Sam
Darnell play a high school basketball
that's how we found them high school
basketball tapes because he broke his
ankle his junior year we had him out in
a camp and he might have thrown 30 balls
I looked over my personal assistant I
looked at Jordan Palmer I said that
kid's gonna play in the NFL and then we
seen every forever Lawrence the first
time we saw him win as a freshman in
high school were like that kid's gonna
play in the NFL
Justin fields the first time we saw him
that kid's gonna play in the NFL Josh
Rosen oh gosh Josh Rosen when we saw him
as a tenth grader that kid's gonna play
in the NFL I mean
you see these kids at tenth 11th grade
and sometimes you just know I mean
there's this no doubt the one they're
gonna go to a great high school get
coached well play it's good people
they're gonna be highly recruited
they're gonna go to a good place in
college gonna have a long leash meaning
they're gonna give it they're going to
be given a chance to fail learn from
their failure come back and succeed I
would say our hit rates really really
high just because we get to see them
relative to all the other quarterbacks
in the country but is there going to be
room for all these quarterbacks in the
NFL that's that's a great this is
they're going to be the most interesting
draft you can start this conversation
right now because you have Herbert lock
Stidham Grier McSorely who am I
forgetting forgetting somebody all these
kids are big-time NFL quarterback cows
but there's no place for them to go in
this year's draft so - Stidham stay in
school this Herbert's stay in school
because if it's lock and McSorely and
greer coming out only is there more is
there room for more than 300 or thier
aligned estate and there's a lot of guys
are really really talented there but
just may not be enough seats for them to
play man I fell now the good thing is
some of them may get drafted later than
they should you know two years ago you
might have been a top six pick now
you're going mid to late first round you
get an opportunity to sit for a couple
years I still think that's the best
formula if you're able to sit for a
little while and watch and learn like
Patrick mahomes so there's going to be
situations like that - I'll say this if
you're doc Prescott in Dallas better
start playing better and better start
playing better there's a lot of guy
better start playing better because
there's guys coming up that can take
their jobs in a heartbeat just like
you're seen in college football great to
visit with you Trent always appreciate
your insights and for more information
on what Trent was talking about where
you can win a trip to Super Bowl media
day
panini kid reporter calm Thank You Trent
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]